[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're gonna discuss what if we
never left North Carolina
what have we never left North Carolina
what do you think our lives will be like
now in in one way we're describing the
lives of uh two guys who didn't ever
leave North Carolina who are really out
there in the universe conjecturing about
their life what if we moved to
California they're having that podcast
and they are having a podcast right now
what if we had decided to move to
California
you know which one's better we're better
we're the better red link we're the take
that we're the best I want to be the
best version of myself
think of it in a parallel universe kind
of way but like
maybe I should you know I want to be my
best self of all of myself
um I could you know what I have a lot to
be grateful what are the chances I feel
pretty high the chance
no the chances are
definitely in the 90th percentile of
links in the universe I don't know how I
feel about the multiple worlds Theory I
believe in my best life it's definitely
the most fun thing to think about the
universe of all the lives that I'm
living
it is very uh boy I you have to have I'm
gonna say a lot of confidence I'm going
to be nice you have to have a lot of
confidence to assume that you this
version of link is in the top 90th
percentage I just don't want all links
here's the way that I think about it
I don't want to change anything well
there's things that I want to change you
know I'm on a journey but I like the
journey I'm on and I like there's some
fundamental things like I don't want to
change fundamental things like I don't
want to change where I live I like
living in California I don't want to
move back to North Carolina I'm going to
show some love to North Carolina the
best I can but
by the way I don't want this to be like
a bashing North Carolina episode I
wasn't thinking I'm a little concerned
that like that I might be insinuating
that my life would suck if I were back
in North Carolina but I get but that's
just Society well there's a lick there's
a better link out there one in the top
10 percentile that doesn't even think
that who is can communicate everything
that you're going to communicate without
insinuating anything negative about
North Carolina and he's better than you
just so you know but you could be you
could you could Ascend to that level
today but I don't think his experience
is going to be any better than mine like
in terms of my like from a selfish
perspective I think I'm living my best
link life of all the link lives that are
being lived I think those are two
different concepts right and all I care
about is my experience I think you're
living from the inside out baby I
completely agree with you I'm very happy
with my outside this threat but I'm not
going to assume that I'm in the top 90th
percentile of all rats out there I don't
know I could be ironically I could be in
the bottom 10 you don't I don't know
what's going on with those other Reds I
don't like to make assumptions about it
anyone including myself in other places
don't be an ungrateful I I'm
either too mutually inclusive being
grateful for my existence does not mean
that I'm better than the other ones
I think that I am so grateful for my
experience that it has to be in the top
90 percentile of all link experiences
okay well and I'm not saying I'm the
best person well I think I'm in the top
79 percentile okay you've gone and I'm
moving up too hold on I'm getting I'm
getting better you said 79 percentile of
all people no no not obvious of all
links okay I'm not I'm not expanding
this I'm not comparing myself to anybody
else except myself you said all people
in every in ad infantum what's that how
do you say that add infinitum infinitum
I don't know how to say those words of
all the links that there are I'm in the
top 79th percentile of good links very
quickly you went from 90th to 70. no it
didn't take me I've made two statements
I am in the top 90 percentile of Link
experiences
like oh but I'm not saying that I'm the
best link there is but I will be so
you're a good link having a great time
yeah
I'm an above mid link having uh a pretty
Primo time uh I'm not gonna make any
assumptions about work and I want to
give you that energy I'm not gloating
and I'm not keeping it to myself I want
I want you to have it and I'm sending it
to you today great great uh I am going
to prove that I'm not in the top 90th
percentile of all ruts but by telling
you a little something before we get
into the subject matter at hand
ah okay I'm I uh
gobble gobble gobble you
know that I along with my
wife Jesse
uh like to watch trashy reality
television we actually haven't been
watching much trash or reality
television as we have
um we're moving out of the pandemic and
life has returned to a new the new
normal there's just not enough time for
all the trash that you've been putting
in and there was a time when uh I mean
early pandemic we were Boy The Bachelor
Bachelorette Bachelor in Paradise so the
full Bachelor uh franchise like Island
love Island and then there was other
other boy Islands uh there was the one
where the people were together and they
were there was a robot that was talking
to them out of a cube and they lost
money every time they had sex like I
can't remember the name of that one but
that was crazy
that was that was way trashier than
Bachelor just so they had to they had to
pay for sex it was a bunch of hot people
it was like too hot to handle it was a
bunch of I think I talked about this on
a previous episode a bunch of hot people
together and then they didn't they
thought they were going to hook up and
then they learned that the rules are if
you hook up you lose money and you all
lose money because it's a collective
prize at the end whatever you can hold
on to
but I have crossed a new threshold oh no
and I want to tell you about it briefly
and tell you what it made me think about
myself and what I did you would never do
this if you still lived in North
Carolina on
Friday night Saturday night
Jesse and I were like let's watch
something funny
okay all right let's watch something
funny stand up special perhaps
um so we started looking for comedy
movies
um we were going to we were like oh that
weird owl movie yeah yeah yeah right
right yeah I'd be into that and and I
was like hold on is this like is it I
know Weird Al's funny but is it funny
and then I then I look up the
description and it's like it's a great
concept it's actually a parody of a
documentary about his life so it has a
lot of things that are not true that
happen well yes because he does music
parodies and now he's done a biopic pair
it's the perfect send-up of weird out
right it's only on Roku but it's free
well I don't have a I don't have a row I
don't have Roku I'm not I mean I don't I
don't have the oh really no
you got to get that yeah but it was like
okay mythical's doing some stuff I know
that I can add the app but it was like I
don't want to I and nothing's easy I
didn't want to go through that process
and I was just I wasn't I was like I'm
in the mood to I have to be amused I'm
yeah cause you have a Roku TV and and I
I want to tell you how great it is well
we also have an apple juice
when they uh pay us
um
so I was like okay uh
and then quickly somehow we went from
being excited about Weird Al
to watching ticket to Paradise take it
to Paradise haven't heard of it George
Clooney Julia Roberts romantic comedy oh
Oh I thought you were going to go to
back to reality TV okay well I'm about
to get there uh I'm I'm this is not a
good movie I'm telling you how we got to
where we ended up getting the the
reviews were rotten I believe uh usually
and I knew this going in it was 57 going
in but I was watching it ironically but
I was like and you know what
for what it was I quite enjoyed it I
just like watching old good-looking
actors gives you a little bit of hope uh
I don't know there's something about it
you like watching old good looking
actors I don't know what it is I'm not
trying I'm not going to sell for analyze
oh I know what it is but I was just we
all know what it is I really like I like
them and they just seem so fun and this
story is just wild and crazy you're into
gilfs man
so and you know what
I think
that this set me up watching Julia
Roberts
kiss George Clooney
set me up and Jesse up okay to seek out
and consume milth Manor
what
MILF so manner so you turned around from
watching that movie and you started
searching I still had an appetite for
old good-looking people
and comedy because it's because it's
your demo uh it's my demo oh because you
oh thanks
you mean I fall into that demo well
you're of that age okay thank you thanks
for I'll take that as a compliment link
you're a parent
um you would you but you would not say
dilf you would not call me a dilf you
won't give me that I'm not prepared to
do that but I've I gotta say that I made
that a gilf joke and I don't know has
anyone ever made that is it that obvious
Grandma I like to yes be friendly with
yes yeah I believe that it's a I thought
I made that up just now no I think it's
like a category
so what what what what a MILF is really
about is it's a I'm gonna blow your
music it's all in relationship to your
age so that's what I'm saying your MILF
is a gilf so when you watch MILFs you're
just watching people your age that
you're attracted to yeah I'm old enough
to be I am old enough to be a grand
person
no
come on now track with me here MILFs to
you are just Attractive people
in order for you to have a MILF
experience you need to it has to be with
the guilt uh yeah 45 my friend well yeah
tell me about this show but I just think
when you think about when I think about
culturally I think about MILFs I think
these MILFs are going to be like women
that you know
are of are my age I'm not thinking
they're going to be older than me I mean
Julia Roberts is uh 55.
so she's a little bit older
um anyway
and there was lots of Buzz about this on
Twitter that's why we ended up watching
you know whatever they did to pay to get
people talking about MILF man or hashtag
MILF Manor on Twitter was very effective
everyone was talking about how you had
to watch this and it was like this feels
like the trashiest possible thing that
we could watch because of one thing that
I did know which I'm going to tell you
and it is the reason that it's going to
blow your mind but also the reason that
I had trouble moving forward with it and
that is this this is the premise of MILF
Manor
you take a bunch of MILFs
and I mean some of these ladies some of
them were early 40s some of them were
like 60. so we're talking like 40 to 60.
that's a good range
and
they're getting to know each other and
then they're like okay now we're gonna
bring in the young men that you are
going to be
consorting with is that a problem
the young men are their sons
oh what all their sons
so it's a bunch of MILFs and their sons
so silphs
I just think you know you know I don't
think you have to carry through the
acronym really uh it would be some some
elfs it would be sons of MILFs some
MILFs son of a myth so what is their
objective
to screw the MILFs but not they don't
need not their own mom well this is of
course where I mean first of all of
course not but good
I only watched episode that would be
trashy I only watched episode one and I
didn't finish it you didn't finish well
because I'll tell you in a second
um when that happened
I was like man I don't like
because one of the kids was 20. yeah one
of the youngest guy there was 20 okay
right and first of all
a lot as many people pointed out on
Twitter yes it is very much true that if
this were reversed if it was a bunch of
old guys and a bunch of young women the
show would have never been made and it
would have been canceled the moment that
someone thought of it
but Hey listen we we we live in an age
of rebelling against the patriarchy so I
get it we can we can we can you know we
can watch shows like this and be
entertained by them in a way that it we
couldn't be if it was reversed but even
then
it just felt
it felt so exploitive is exploitative
exploitative
in a way that all reality TV is but I
was just like this is
because it was like the mix of the
family unit it was like oh man like I
was thinking about the casting of it
first of all you have to cast a MILF and
you have to find a son and you have to
find them that they have to be willing
to go on a show and somehow essentially
be told that they're not going on the
same show I don't know how they did that
but what is this going to do I mean
obviously this is crazy Dynamics because
you've got right off the bat you've got
this you know there's one couple where
these two dudes you know they're growing
out or whatever you know two 20
something year old guys just growing out
and then one of the guys moms comes over
and then he's like flirting with her and
then he goes to that Mom's bedroom with
her on night one
and then her son comes in after her and
is like Mom no you just met this guy
and it was like yeah exactly so the
whole is happening in real life why not
just document it
um
but the thing that made me turn it so I
was very uncomfortable because it just
felt if it's one thing when you got a
bunch of people who go on The Bachelor
or a bunch of people who are going like
love Island and it's like they know
exactly what they're getting themselves
into and they're only ruining their own
lives you know
but not their mom's life or their son's
life together as a like a family unit in
a way that it just got too it just got a
little
uncomfortable but then there was the the
one of the first sort of things that
they did like one of the set pieces or
whatever
challenges was
we're gonna put all these boys all these
some MILFs into blindfolds
and they're gonna take their shirts off
be in blindfolds and then
uh sorry the mom isn't blindfolded the
moms are blindfolded The Sounds have
their shirts off and the moms are going
to feel the bodies of these guys to find
their son
oh
so they're like oh oh like feeling their
abs and their in their chest and their
shoulders and their faces so what
they're hoping for is for there to be
like this is definitely not my son so
I'm gonna start being real flirtatious
with this body
and did that happen well of course but I
didn't that's when I cut it off oh good
for you during that challenge I was like
man I like wow I like watching trashy TV
and I and I don't mind people doing
stuff that makes them look stupid and I
listen I may be you may be coming across
as a as a judgey guy right now but it
was just like I even I cannot be
entertained by this I am so relieved
like Rhett McLaughlin has a line no yeah
I met my Limitless Manor y'all
and it's in its uh mother on son
touching televised touching
and you know what
uh
okay you you had to get to the line I
guess to know it existed but like we're
not gonna say what this airs on this is
not a sponsor people can find it do they
want gonna promote it because I'm not
gonna say how to spell MILF or Manor
because here's the twist that I think
they probably should do if they didn't
do but I'm not going to watch to find
out I'm just saying if I was a you know
just soulless producer of this type of
TV
here's what I would have done I would
have made sure that one of the sets of
MILF and some MILF was a stepson
you would have done that and then they
end up hooking up because that's what
everybody's into
that's like the
look at the data dude in multiple States
the number one porn category is step it
is is having sex with your stepmom or
your stepsister like that's that's what
people are into man and so these
producers know that
and if they're if someone's using the
term smart with quotes quotations here
if they're smart one of them was a
stepson and they're gonna mix it up and
I just think that at this point I don't
know man I just it made me too
uncomfortable and not because you're now
making me uncomfortable but could I use
this as an opportunity to
shift and segue into what we actually
wanted to talk about because I'd love to
do that I want to leave the MILF manner
I cannot yeah can I exit yeah yeah but
what if we get invited to dilf
desert I'm trying to think of uh I don't
want to go to another desert is it Palm
Springs uh Joshua Tree Joshua Tree
delft desert
there's not another location that starts
with a D
but just so you understand this means
that you're single so I don't know I
mean I I mean you're no plans for to be
single anytime soon it also means I'm
not eligible it also means that Lily
will be joining you uh at delft Desert
so there's a there's a lot and I don't
and I can't go because
I don't have a daughter
and I'm also married
and you're not a dilf I thought you were
going to say that uh and I'm not a dilf
okay that's good
ear biscuits is supported by chime they
say money can't buy happiness but not
worrying about money can definitely
boost your mood you know what I'm saying
that's where chime comes in they were
named the number one loved banking app
with payday up to two days early and fee
free overdrafts up to 200 they offer
Financial Peace of Mind in your wallet
all of this with no annual fees no large
security deposits and no credit checks
to apply see for yourself why chime is
so loved at chime.com ear that's
chime.com ear chime is a financial
technology company not a bank banking
services and debit card provided by The
Bancorp bake or stripe Bank in a members
FDIC
Early Access to direct deposit funds
depends on payer spot me eligibility
requirements and overdraft limit Supply
seechime.com spot me chime was the 2021
number one most downloaded banking app
in the US according to apptopia
would you be watching this show at all
if you still live in North Carolina good
question would you be the type of person
that would then talk about that show on
this show better question would we even
be doing this show if we were in North
Carolina let's talk about what we'd be
like let's talk about that we've
independently prepared some thoughts
first let's promote some some stuff
that's important to us it is the fourth
we are celebrating the fourth
anniversary of the mythical Society
crazy man we've been in love we've been
doing the mythical Society for as long
as we went to high school
and uh you know when we celebrate the
anniversary we do a lot of deals we you
can sign up for all levels at discounts
and there's special things that we're
giving away Etc go over to mythical
society.com if you're interested never
been a better time to join the mythical
Society I mean specifically if you want
to join third degree
um I believe it's annual and you do that
in this month you get a choice of a
previous yeah
um quarterly collectible it's the only
way to get that
uh unless you want to pay like some
absorbitant price on eBay
I think that starts to happen because
these things are Collectibles
Collectibles it's the only way to get it
get some that while supplies last so
check it out how did you approach this
conversation because we each jotted down
some notes and we haven't discussed this
so it's just a fun question what if we
never left North Carolina
I divided it into three categories
um one was how would things be different
professionally
the other was how would things be
different
spiritually okay because that is a topic
of conversation for a lot of folks who
believe that a lot of things happen
because of our move and the third was
more broadly personally
which I guess does encompass
spirituality but okay the kind of person
we would be I basically did that too
um yeah my thoughts first went to your
first category so maybe let's start
there where it's like um
I like the thing that I said like just
as a blanket statement before I get into
any conjecture about what it is
specifically we would be doing
I just think as a performer I would be a
lot more meek
like I don't think I would have just
I wouldn't be so unabashedly whatever
you would call me I think there's this
Dynamic of being
out here that accelerated this like
I can be I can really embody a like a
performer and I'm really talking about
embody a performer what does that even
mean
um that I could go more extreme like my
hair wouldn't look like this if I still
lived in North Carolina
it would look a little different
like I wouldn't be finding my my dress
code Vibe and I know this is kind of
personal so I'm mixing categories yeah
but yeah but I'm just making a point
that like these things are all a
function of I think me being a performer
and giving myself permission to be weird
like I don't have
I think if I was back home
I would
there's this different Force than there
is in La like the center of cultural
gravity is a little more
normal there's you know it's not an
entertainment Hub there's people doing
all types of work you rub shoulders with
some you could rub shoulders with a
farmer
um a tech executive
a factory worker
um
uh a philosopher you can rub shoulders
with all these people in North Carolina
it's it's it's it's a lot broader a
spectrum and slice of
life at least for for us and I think
that like
yeah and you can rub shoulders with
artists but certainly
but there's such a high concentration of
people expressing themselves here that
like there's less of a barrier to
overcome to like do something to be just
just
how did I say it
expression just be weird if yourself be
is it just yourself be if you is weird
do you want to talk about the personal
first
because that's what you I mean that's
but
I guess I was trying to say that to say
that like
I'll go either way you want to go by
finishing when it comes to my
performance
like if I leave the studio and I went
back home and
I was seeing my family members more
often I was seeing my friends back home
that have nothing to do with the
entertainment industry and I was in
those type of Social Circles where
there's just more head scratching in
terms of like
okay the sensitivity to deviating from
the norm is higher back home and I think
that I would have absorbed that and it
would have slowed my
accelerating decline into the weirdness
that is I believe my true self
accelerating decline that's an
interesting thing but that's how that's
how I think people back home would have
seen it and I would have feel like I
would have had to answer to it so I'd be
like man I saw your video the other day
and I'll be like you know a little
sheepish about it and I would be
thinking about those people more often
like
well I think there's a lot I think
there's a lot to unpack with that
I kind of want to save my thoughts on
that to the end okay
because so pick apart which part of it
you want to go with we can come back to
all of it I mean I was if I was thinking
about
the way that our career progressed and
the way that
what happened to us professionally with
mythical
okay and the specific things that we
have done okay and accomplished over the
past decade since moving and
the first thing that hit me was just a
general principle of the fact that we
tend to be opportunistic which is a
negative sounding word but we're not
particularly
um specifically Vision driven we talked
about this in the book of mythicality
that we pick a direction and go instead
of outlining or manifesting exactly what
it is that we want to accomplish and we
also are interested in a lot of
different things if you look at the past
10 years
you know if you look at our entire
career so beyond that like we've made a
documentary we've written a non-fiction
book we've written the novel we've had a
podcast we've that was an interview show
we've had a podcast that's just talking
to each other we've had a daily talk
show we've made a bunch of music videos
we've made a bunch of sketches we had a
reality TV show we had a scripted TV
show
I we've we've had multiple music things
happen together and individually
we've done so many different things
we're into a lot of different things in
the past you should say 12 years yeah
you can argue that we've been better at
some things than others and that's true
but I think there is a propensity to try
a lot of different things and to fill
opportunity you know opportunity
opportunity
with an idea like we're kind of reactive
so let's just say specifically what
happened was we moved out here to do
commercial Kings to film that pilot and
to kind of do a trial run and let's say
for whatever reason we had decided no
we're not going to
be out here and we go back to North
Carolina
the biggest inciting event that led to
us growing mythical was receiving money
from YouTube to make the mythical show
which was independent of us being in
California had nothing to do with us
moving had to do with the relationship
that we had with YouTube at the time and
also our attraction on YouTube which
again had all happened before moving but
it was based on a few few seasons of
Good Mythical Morning which we launched
here
if we were back in North Carolina so it
hinged on that if we were back in North
Carolina I do think we still would have
made good mythical morning because
the reasons we made it
were we were the show got canceled then
you reordered commercial King so they're
like we had to build something and that
was like part of the strategy was daily
video strategy but it was based on good
morning cheat Link in which we started
back when we were in Fuquay Varina so I
think that we still would have gone back
to hey
we still would have had the idea of Good
Mythical Morning we would have done it
so I think that I like to think that it
still would have I definitely still
would have done it
but again so much so much pivots on or
depends on
very small choices that end up having
big effects so obviously really big
thing that happened when we started the
mythical show was hiring Stevie now
it's hard enough to find a producer a
good producer right we you know we have
hired we had hired people on like a
one-off basis before that we wouldn't
necessarily be like yeah we want to
bring this person in to be like a
full-time producer with us yeah but with
Stevie we found a producer that really
understood what we were trying to
accomplish creatively but then we just
kind of got lucky that she was also on
board to help grow the company she was
committed like she was she was on board
and capable of that as well
and if and the chances of finding that
person especially 11 years ago
are much higher in Los Angeles than they
they were at the time in in Raleigh now
Raleigh has become you could totally do
it now much people are doing it now yeah
right you know there's all types of
um North carolina-based
successful creators right
um so what so just so we could do it now
but then but then we couldn't have done
it we could we couldn't have found the
team
and
it wouldn't have been it would have it
wouldn't have been as as an why can't
neither one of us can talk to yeah let's
just you know
it's you know first day of the week the
way that we were hiring out here was
kind of an accelerant but that would not
have been throwing any fuel to the fire
back home and what that did in building
the team in the way that we did enabling
us to make good mythical morning and
make a bunch of other stuff led to the
specific things that we ended up doing
so my theory is that if we were back in
North Carolina the chances of us finding
somebody to help us grow our team but
also finding people to fill the needs
that we had in a team would have been
greatly reduced but the thing that would
have remained is this tenacious
uh opportunism I'll call it yeah and
this creative drive to try a lot of
things and we would have done a bunch of
different things but also at the time we
saw YouTube not as a long-term career
but as a stepping stone and we saw it as
something to get us into what we thought
was better traditional media of some
kind but what would that have been in
North Carolina and my theory is that we
would have
made some kind of move into
broadly speaking documentary film that's
the what we call self-insertion
documentary film like Morgan Spurlock
which I mean it actually has a whole new
meaning
now but the basically when you make a
documentary about yourself doing
something you think we would have gone
back I think we would have done that
because it's the most ambitious
uh and creatively but the lowest barrier
of entry and you can do it from anywhere
because we'd already done it with
looking for Miss Locklear yeah I'm just
I'm saying this is just one path at the
same time we got that job with Coke and
McDonald's to make that commercial yeah
I think we may have also been like let's
move into making commercials and that's
going to be our thing and law and then
all of a sudden let's let's start a
studio in Raleigh and it would be like a
you know making ads for people there's
so many things that we can talk
ourselves into getting excited about
yeah that the number of options would
have been endless but the chances that
it ended up happening the way that it
happened here and specifically the
things that have come out of that no
very very low
yeah I do I'd like to think that we
would still be successful and that we we
would have found a way I'm pretty
confident in agreement that we would
have found and it's also much easier to
support yourself in North Carolina the
the level of success that we would have
had to achieve in order to just make a
good living that was at least better
than our the living that we were making
as people on staff for campus Crusade
where were we living now like do you
think we'd be living in key Hills
living in Bowie's Creek uh you think
we'd be living in like I think we would
be up in a I mean like good stuff
happening in Raleigh we gotta you know
our alma mater is there
you think we'd be out there in like
Coolville Carrboro
I bet you we'd be in um
I bet you we'd be in Raleigh well it's
funny because a lot of my thoughts about
where we would be living are kind of
based on
my thoughts on the spiritual part I
wasn't actually thinking about it
related to the to the to the
professional part I think professionally
we'd be up there because eventually we'd
be hiring people and like there's more
of a center up there you know but I
because I don't think we would go the
route of like having a huge like huge
warehouses on some former tobacco field
in Harnett County like I like the idea
of that story a little bit like being
outside of Fuquay and like just having
these huge
um like a campus of
huge barns
that like we could just film crazy stuff
in
so maybe we I think maybe maybe we would
have I don't know I I think ultimately
we'd be pulled more into the the city
with some people if we had
had stayed their course on YouTube in
particular and not have like lost
you know focus on that which is what I
would have hoped we'd have stayed
creators and not just like commercial
producers right because again no one
really had the vision that there was
going to be so much potential
in what what is happening on YouTube
right and
if we had to like those other Ventures
had not distracted us too much and we
had remained creators
then I think that it would look a lot
more like
a lot of these creators that are in
places outside of of North Carolina we
talked to um
I can't remember Linus uh no well yeah
so we talked to Linus Tech tip Susan
who's in Canada we talked to him at the
YouTube Summit but then we we talked to
another guy who's down in Houston
um
get a big Warehouse yeah it's I can't
remember he's kind of like a Mr Beast e
type Creator uh in that you know
the amount of money that has moved into
the system
over the past five six years
if we had to stayed the course then we
would have been able to generate the
type of money where you can be like hey
let's get this Warehouse because that's
what happens when
I mean yes we've got a great Studio
uh the rent is ridiculous but
if you're somewhere else if you're in
the South or if you're in a less
developed place like you you can be you
can get some giant building or build a
giant building right you know you can do
what dude perfect did yeah I mean that
would I mean now they're talking about
building a 100 million dollar campus
it's like an amusement park I'm not
saying that that would have happened
maybe but I think they're like just a
you know like a dirty water park version
of that but I think that we would have
you know if we had stayed creators we
would have done something along those
lines that you see happening in these
different places around the country
what would what would be making I don't
know because
so much of the percentage of content
that we've put out into the world
a such a high percentage of it is good
mythical morning because it's just
happened so often it's a long video
every single day and it's been going for
you know over a decade and it wouldn't
have developed and maybe I don't know so
it could it could vary easily not have
developed it could have fizzled out and
at this point you know and it has been
this way for quite some time it's not
like doing GMM
has kept us
for the most part from doing anything
else that we wanted to do
uh
but if we didn't have it
it's also given us so much opportunity
to try other things that if we didn't
have that I think we would have stuck in
we would have stayed in more traditional
Creator mode which is
you just make videos as you make videos
but but I don't think yes but I don't
think we would have stayed in Fuquay
I agree with that we would have migrated
a little bit
North
let's skip to the spiritual stuff
because that that is a big part of this
too it's like you know when I talked
about my spiritual journey and like
leaving evangelicalism
there was like there was a lot of stuff
percolating in like the year or two
before leaving uh North Carolina which
also just part and parcel was me leaving
my church that I was very involved in
but like I was having all this behind
the scenes like crisis of conscious and
conscience and not feeling like
um just feeling like I was playing a
role
not in service but like just try and
fake it till you make it kind of thing
and like so I started to become very
disillusioned
with my church experience and my um
just the way that I was conducting my
relationship with God in quotes I guess
you would say but he felt more guilty
about it rather than like I don't
believe this uh yes more so there was
there was all parts of that I mean I was
questioning it because of my
of my experience like it was very much a
heart exercise for me
first and like a feeling exercise than a
brain exercise which is I think more the
way that you describe it
um so for me yeah I was disillusioned
with my experience
and
I started having conversations with
Christy and like
um confiding in one or two other people
that was like I just don't know if I can
keep this up
and then we had the opportunity to move
out to LA and it was just like okay this
is going to make it a lot easier
you know it was it was like cutting the
cord now I did start going to church
when I was out here but I was just
attending I wasn't involved I wasn't
like very I wasn't deeply entrenched in
it in terms of like leadership oh they
leadership they need me and like they're
counting on me and like I I don't want
to be that guy who just quits you know
and have people counting on me
that was a part of it anyway I I all of
that to me sets the stage for
man I think I would be in this difficult
place where I would be like
there would have been many years of like
straddling the fence
without the move to LA I would have just
been like
I don't know if it would have been a few
more it would have definitely taken a
few more years for it to boil over for
me and be like I can't be involved
in my church in the way that I am
because I'm just not
I'm not into it I'm just not
I just don't I don't believe it
to the to the extent that I've been
trying to believe it I I just felt like
I gotta I gotta go elsewhere I gotta
leave this environment and but like that
would be that would have been really
hard for me because I felt like that
would have I just would have been
it's not
it's it would involve a lot of hard
conversations
and it would have
like I just put this imaginary person on
a pedestal that was like the person who
does the right thing is that they serve
and they trust and
they they trust Beyond themselves
that they're doing the right thing
they're trusting God not themselves and
I just need to do more of that and I
would convince myself to just
hang around and be miserable I think and
I think
because I actually thought about it
um
I think kind of what you're getting at
is
I think it's actually less related to
the culture
uh and more related to your the specific
church for both of us and let me explain
that
because the biggest
sort of traumatic element of it would
have been leaving the specific churches
we were at yeah I absolutely considered
them like a type of family and mine was
my family
my dad started my church my dad was an
elder at the church yeah so it's like
um
it so it was like so you that's how I
think about it in that context of the
church that we were going to
and oh it's been would have been so
difficult to have those conversations
with your your actual family and then
your church family it's just like
everybody everybody would have an
opinion an active opinion and you would
be there for it even if you weren't
going anymore yeah so I so I have
um I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you uh very
quickly because you never know what
could have happened right three
different options as to what could have
happened so what actually this is just
for you yeah yeah so and I think it'll
you you will probably find that you
relate to these different options but so
what actually happened was
I had a deep crisis of faith that had
been unfolding for many years in North
Carolina to the point that I had gone to
my pastor and the thing that I had told
him at the time was
I do not believe in the historicity of
the Old Testament you know specifically
the origin story Genesis the Adam and
Eve thing like you know I was in a place
where
like these people didn't exist man you
know like this is uh this is a myth this
is a creation myth and I'm Wrecking
trying to reconcile what that means but
it was very easy for me to
um you know understand that this was
going to lead to losing confidence and I
was already losing confidence in more
parts of the Bible and right up until
the time that we left I had gotten to a
place where my confidence in the Bible
and specifically in the the gospels and
the person of Jesus
which as a concept I was still very much
in love with Jesus loved the the concept
of of Grace love the idea of uh the
gospel
and God you know finding a way to have a
relationship with us and like all that
was a beautiful picture but my
confidence in the underlying
reasons to believe that had eroded to
the point that I specifically remember
on that road trip
to California which incidentally a video
series came out of that I don't know if
you remember this but
I seem to remember that I got very real
with you I you knew where I was at but I
remember on that trip in some of those
long conversations that we had in
between trying to make videos was when I
was basically saying dude
this is not true like whole cloth like
this is not true like I can't I can't
hold on to I'm afraid I can't hold on to
any of this
yeah that was where I was telling you
that and and and it was when it landed
on me first of all I wasn't surprised
because it wasn't totally out of the
blue it wasn't an announcement there
were like little conversations yeah yeah
even back there but I just remember
being able to have some like really
uninterrupted long conversations where
it was just yeah yeah and also like what
does this mean about moving to
California like what you know and the
way that it landed on me was I was in a
place of
this isn't I can't do this anymore I
can't do this anymore like it was very
much about that experience for me and
just being
you know the way that I interacted with
the belief system was just like I just I
was I was beating myself down and it was
just like
you know I think Decades of that my
journals prove it yeah to myself so it's
like
um yeah we're coming from two different
places but yeah on that trip when we
were coming from the same place and
going to the same place we were having
all these conversations so yeah I I
don't remember the specific conversation
but that's how I process what you were
saying and because I was having so much
inner turmoil and I did not want to
leave the faith because I didn't there
was no there was no alternative that
seemed attractive to me and I still was
saying you know what Peter said which is
where where you know if where am I going
to go if it isn't with you where am I
going to go that was the mentality that
had that was what I was writing in my
journal
so coming to California and then
immediately getting involved in a church
uh that was a la church now yes
Evangelical they were Evangelical and
basically believed all the same things
that my church back home believed but it
presented in a different way and it and
there were people in the congregation
who had a lot of different ideas there
were people in the congregation who
believed in evolution there were people
in the congregation who thought it was
okay to be gay you know what I'm saying
so there were things that I was like
okay this feels like uh I can kind of do
this and I'll just I'm gonna you know by
faith just hold on to this Jesus concept
and yeah me too and just kind of be an
LA Christian for a while so that's what
ended up happening and of course you
know the story it didn't last very long
eventually it was like I don't see any
reason to hold on to this and you know
I'm jumping into the sea of uncertainty
we've done a podcast or two on that
but if we had not moved so what are the
three options so you're mine option one
would have been because I've I've said
the thing about being on the fence for
me option one would have been I would
have taken these concerns very directly
back to my pastor and to the elders as a
as a leader in the church I was leading
a Bible study at the time I led a Bible
study for basically my entire adult life
from College on
I was always leading a Bible study
um
and gone and said this is what I'm I
need you guys to pray for me because I
have all these doubts and I think that
so option one would have been going
through this deep spiritual discontent
but then through ultimately what I
believe would have would have been
social pressure
I'm not blame this is just how the
church Works through social pressure I
would have been kind of pressured back
into just doubling down on my faith so
going through a crisis of faith and
feeling like you're about to lose it and
then realizing that you don't want to
lose it because all the circumstances
would keep you there you're still in the
South you're still in this community
your parents your in-laws everybody is
going to the same church they all
believe the same thing there's just so
many forces keeping you in and it's so
difficult to get out of that I think
that in spite of and I'm pretty
strong-willed you know me I think that
this is um this might be
I don't know what the probability is but
this is at least there's at least a 33
chance that this would have happened and
I would have like the age Jesus was when
he died I would have doubled down on my
faith and kind of gone back in okay
interesting only only to probably lead
to an eventual crisis of Faith another
10 years down the road just just so
we're clear let me share my version
because the information would have never
changed yeah yeah yeah uh my version of
that scenario uh yeah I was the main way
that I was serving at my church was
deleting the music
like the band leader you know the
strumming the guitar and the we have we
there was an organ
playing the organ this is it was it was
yeah something for everybody wonderful
um I worked really hard at it
um
but it was yeah it was I started from
increasingly like a hypocrite because of
like my crisis of conscience behind the
scenes but I think I would have gotten
to a point where
yeah I think I would have gone to
um
the leadership at the church which you
know what I've and I love those people
you know I have I have very fond
memories and and Chrissy and I have over
the past two years we've reconnected
with uh the pastor
uh you know Warren and Kathy we've
reconnected with them we've seen him a
couple of times because they've come out
here to visit their family and like
and then when we went back we saw him
over Christmas for like for an hour or
so
um so I love him to death it's been
great to reconnect with them
um
anyway
I think I would have gone to them and
said listen there's some stuff going on
with me we can you know we can get into
the Spiel of it um but I think it would
be like I need to take a step back I
need to take a step out of service like
being active like on stage like people
can if you choose to look at me while
you're like like trying to worship God
like I'm up there like trying to trying
to do it in the right way or everything
it's like I would have I would have I
would have stepped away from that and
I've been like I'm still gonna attend
but I got some stuff that I need to work
on I need to focus on it and being in a
visible position of
um
leadership
what is a big distraction for me
personally to to what I need to work
through
and
um
I don't know how I would have
yeah but like
and what would have come of that I don't
know I feel like
I'm surprised to hear that you in this
scenario yeah in this scenario you'd
have been you'd have been like
you said pulled back in but like you
would have gone back in and like doubled
down
uh
yeah if your second option is more of
like staying on the fence I've already
said that's where I think I would be
um I don't I don't think I would have
I think I would have tried to double
back down but then I would have found
myself in the same place another six
months down the road in none of my
scenarios just because you know me and
my personality none of my scenarios
involve me being disengaged with it
I don't disengage right yeah I I I I I
move I move towards something
kind of aggressively and with conviction
and I like figure out everything that I
need to think about it like that that's
my personality is not to disengage and
become passive in any way so what's the
second so uh or the third the I'll go
I'll go to the third and come back to
the second right so the more extreme
version of this or you know the other
end of the spectrum
would have been
that I would have decided
uh because again the information didn't
change like I didn't move to LA and get
new information that made my faith
crumble the information was available
and is available that caused me to lose
confidence in in the Bible
um
and to then finally consider that I
might have been wrong all along
that still would have been there and if
I had just been like listen regardless
of the social pressure regardless of how
uncomfortable it's going to be
to not believe in the context of
North Carolina living in the same town
with my parents and my in-laws and
everybody who believes a very particular
thing
[Music]
there is a version in which I would have
said
publicly at least to them
I no longer believe this
and move aggressively in the other
direction I did go through what every
but not every but many deconverted
deconstructing people go through is like
an angry atheist phase where like every
single thing that you think about
the religion is negative and you see
that you see the negative side of every
single thing from Christianity and you
you know you you you listen to all the
atheist people and and so it's about
what you're against now that you kind of
become a fundamentalist on the other end
of the spectrum yeah I think that there
is and I know people like this I know
people who have uh
in the context of the South because I
think that in some ways
it kind of forces you to take you have
to sort of take aside aggressively
because it's so culturally in in in
ingrained that you kind of have to be
like I'm a fish swimming in a Upstream
now and and I'm going to and all the
stuff that comes along with that
so it'd be like not going to church at
all
um you know kind of like debating my
family and friends and it there there's
a version of me that kind of took like a
sort of an angry path and so I'm not you
can do all that without being angry I'm
not saying that being an atheist makes
you angry
uh I'm just saying that for me because
the way I would lean into it I
anticipate that there would be a version
of it that was like actively opposed to
it all and wanting to tear it all down
right which then that is that where you
get into like you have to move to
another County
uh you have to find some like-minded
people to I probably have to move into
like Raleigh Durham or whatever you know
um but I was actually thinking about
moving in the context of the second
option which is what I'll call my
staying on the fence which I think is
really really common for people who are
our age and younger who are
deconstructing in the South and that is
I'm just gonna go to a more Progressive
Church I'm gonna go to a place that just
doesn't believe as stringently about all
these different things it isn't so much
about dogma and doesn't have a dogmatic
world view Isn't So Evangelical maybe
I'll go to a Mainline Church you know
some you know or I'll go to just kind of
a progressive church and there's a haul
kinds of flavors of that and there's
flavors of that in the triangle and it
would be like
I want to maintain a Christian identity
and I want to maintain a faith in Jesus
and I still believe in the resurrection
and I still believe that
you know
I'm leaning into the mystery of God and
trusting Jesus through this this thing
but like
have a different kind of faith on the
other side that's still a faith which
listen I really respect
I respect people who take any one of
these paths because it's their story and
their circumstances and I don't think
any one of these paths is necessarily
wrong or right
um I think it's so based on your
particular circumstances and your
disposition is why you end up doing one
thing or another
but so this middle scenario would
probably have involved moving again but
and you'd also want to be an environment
I I that was
affirming regardless of like your sexual
orientation or your gender identity you
know
um I think that
I would I would I would hope that I
would have ended up in that same place I
think it would have I would have
observed your experience if you took the
middle path because it would have taken
me longer you know got a lot of love for
the people in my church
and like I just valued the commitment to
well if this is your family you stick
with them no matter no matter what even
if you disagree with them whatever so
like I would just try to blend in but I
think
it would take more years but I would
have like slowly slowly faded it faded
into the background and then shown up
somewhere else
yeah I don't think I could have actively
achieved this Middle Ground sort of
still remaining a Christian but becoming
a new type of Christian and stayed at my
old church because
I want to be involved you know and if
that was what I believed I I would it
wouldn't be consistent with the things
that you have to believe in order to be
in leadership at my old church and so
I'd have to go to a place where like
well that's not a requirement
and when it comes to the you know it's
interesting when it comes to the LGBT
stuff which was something that I think
where we were you know 15 years ago was
okay like you know hey I don't I don't
really have a problem with this like I
don't it doesn't seem like I know some
of these folks and like I don't have a
problem with it but I kind of know that
I'm supposed to think that God has a
problem with it and I think that there's
a lot of people who are still in that
situation where I'm just not going to
sing it's like hey like yeah it doesn't
seem like there's anything wrong with
this on its face
uh and I know gay people and they seem
pretty cool but yeah it seems like the
Bible is pretty clear about this so God
must have an opinion about this and this
must be his standard and so I'm going to
stand by that and it's a I mean it's a
difficult position to maintain
but I just want to make the point that
there are a lot of people who uh go to
churches that are not affirming
and also don't believe that God is okay
with
anything else you know anything beyond
just marriage between a man and a woman
uh who are not bigots
you know I'll say that it's like it
doesn't automatically mean that they're
a bigot I think it means that they
subscribe to an ideology that gives them
a bigoted view of this situation but I
I'm back into it but I think a lot of
people in their heart of hearts are like
yeah I don't like I would never mistreat
somebody who was different than me in
this way but I kind of know that this is
what we're supposed to think and so it
does affect your behavior and I'm not
saying it's okay and it's excusable I'm
just saying that the reason I know that
that's the case is because I was one of
those people
I was one of those people I existed I I
was one of those people yeah right yeah
yeah there's also people who have a
like a
um a well-formed
uh analysis interpretation of the Bible
and come to a different conclusion that
that they are affirming of all
uh of all forms of well and that's what
a progress like a Progressive Church
would probably they would be like okay
yeah these verses you know they have a
way of explaining it that I don't
necessarily agree is uh you know I don't
know if you can if it's an intact view
but I agree with the view but you're
saying you would end up in a place like
that uh yeah in the middle way yeah and
again
so I could tell my family that I was
still going to church every week because
like when you because you see them all
the time you see them all the time like
it's easy to like not go to church for
for months while you're figuring this
stuff out and not have to answer to
anybody so it's like and wait yeah
they'd be kind of judging you for the
church that you're going to like oh he's
going to that liberal Church
like the distance allowed me to not have
to like to have my process and not have
to be answer prematurely to people who
were interested in and concerned like
family and friends who would have been
interested in concerned it's just like
it wasn't on their radar
uh
uh good friends outside the church
I mean all our friendships were people
who were you know people from our campus
ministry days uh people from our
churches and then our family and there
was more than enough of those folks to
go around and we all agreed about the
basic things regarding Christianity
and so that would have been a difficult
thing coming out here we immediately
became friends with a whole lot of
different people including a lot of
people who had very similar backgrounds
and were coming out of that and they
were at some point along their sort of
deconstruction journey and so you
immediately kind of connect with these
people and you can commiserate a little
bit and we would not have had that in
North Korea oh God and then the time you
talk about the hiring part like we were
talking about the creative business part
and like how we were we'd be limiting
who we could hire at that time like the
other thing that like every all the
members of the mythical crew that we
hired like all different points of view
and walks of life and ages and you know
experiences and uh
hobbies and
orientations and gender identities it's
like all of this is is
I mean
we knew that it was the right thing to
do to like say hey we gotta we want to
have a lot of different perspectives who
are like baking into everything that
we're making it's the right thing to do
and and it's and good can come from it
but I can say from experience like
having made that decision again and
again with hiring that like then it's
like you're you're rubbing shoulders
with so many people that are that are D
that came up in a different way from us
and that are different people yeah than
a lot of people that we would have been
able to interact with on a daily basis
in a workplace environment than if we
were back home at that time given what
we were trying to build it would have
been a lot smaller it would have been a
lot more limited and so then our
exposure
would have been
um
yeah would it wouldn't have been nearly
as robust and eye-opening
as it is out here yeah you know and it's
that's that's just a
that's just something practically that
would have happened even if we wanted
something different to happen
and we put it all the same things in
place it would have just been a lot
slower and smaller yeah that I think
that my conclusion
is regardless of which path I took
spiritually my best guess is that it was
very likely that in each one of those
scenarios I would have at some point
ended up with another crisis of faith
that probably led to somewhere like I am
right now which is kind of like
I don't know a whole lot about what
happens after you die and I think and I
don't think anybody does okay this my
world view broadly speaking
I think I would have gotten there but I
think it accelerated by moving to Los
Angeles there's no doubt that that
that's the case I think it slowed it
down a little bit initially
but I think that
on the whole it would have been harder
for it to happen in North Carolina but
it would have eventually happened
because there's no Regional nature to
any of the information that was really
key in changing my mind
I still would have gotten to it
eventually yeah I don't know photo got
into it because I mean I'm I'm still
actively
not I I don't mean to say still I am
actively working through in therapy now
um just coming to grips with how much
how much power I uh externalize and give
away to other people in terms of like
perceived judgment like I want
you know I want to perform for people so
that I get the response the responsive
acceptance and you're good and you're
okay and like I just have a proclivity
to do that
you know and when we moved out here
you know it was we had our relationship
where we could like
keep each other in check because like is
this who you really are it's like we
know each other so well that like
there's this undercurrent in our
conversations that's like
we would we would both know
if
either one of us was making a choice
that was unhealthy and like we're going
off the deep end like you know what I'm
gonna start snorting cocaine it's like
is that really who you want to be is
that really who you are right you know
it's like uh we never had that
conversation that's not something that's
ever happened for the record but yeah
I'm just using that as a hyperbolic
example right
um
we can keep we've
we we keep ourselves true to ourselves
right there's that's a healthy level of
accountability and then with obviously
with Christy and you with Jesse like
there's this like we know each other
there's that very much that Dynamic of
and then with the with the kids and but
we were building friendships it's like
when you move to a new place you can
kind of redefine so much of yourself so
it's like
if I was still back home all of my
relatives it's like everybody has this
long-staining idea of who you are and
how you fit in like everybody in my
church it was like this certain they saw
me in a certain way so it's like
so many more relationships where
I would have this perceived judgment I'm
not saying they're all judging me but
like
it would be very easy to feel like they
all have an opinion on anything I do
that would deviate from the norm right
and that's a very
powerful pull for me like I've
identified that that like
I want to start internalizing more of
who who
what like I'm operating from a place of
within to without versus a place of like
from without to within if that even
makes sense well I mean that's the it's
that's the identity of a three okay even
more so than uh so just the Crux of that
having all of these people who you've
grown up with for heaven's sakes you
walk around the Walmart and the Target
and like you see somebody who has has a
long-standing idea of who you are that's
red I know I know his parents you know I
know I read that article about you in
the paper it's like you're doing a weird
thing you know all of these
I don't understand it all of that stuff
would play into just kind of
bogging down we just wouldn't be in I
would not I would not be in the same
place well so you kind of get into the
personal which I think is a good thing
to end on
I completely agree and relate I think
that I am I still I even though I get a
little bit better every single year at
this I still am too interested in being
liked
still care too much about being liked
and if you're the kind of person who
cares about being liked you will be
molded by your environment in a way that
is you know the more you want to be
liked
the more you will be molded by your
environment
and so that for for me that's stuff like
this so yes I have a job just by by
default being a creative person and
having a creative job you're already a
little bit in left field like
this guy does some weird stuff
and it gives you the right I suppose to
dress a certain way to wear your hair a
certain way you know it's like you don't
you look at me and you're like well
I doubt he's an accountant
right right right I I doubt
and I think that that would still be the
case but the thing is that in Los
Angeles
everywhere you go you see people who are
trying to make a statement with the way
they are presenting themselves
and usually that statement is I'm cool
I'm Different
um I know something that you don't know
I got more money than you got whatever
like right
that is less pronounced
in North Carolina
because a lot of times the social
pressures in North Carolina especially
outside of a metro area but I would say
even within you know in the south
a lot of the time
the pressure is I want you to know that
like I'm I'm still cool I'm still okay
like you know here's a perfect example
when we were back in in North Carolina
recently
um
I had to meet
some guys who I got several estimates on
some tree removal that's being done on
the property there
and
I was kind of like looking at myself in
the mirror
before you met him and I was like and I
had my hair I had a man bun you know I
don't like having my hair down when I'm
like actually doing something besides
entertaining people most of the time of
the way okay and so the way that I can
wear my hair is by putting it either
doing a half bun or a full bun
and I was like I don't want to meet this
tree guy with a man bun yeah again
this is a problem
but I'm also thinking like I kind of
want this guy I don't want this guy to
think I'm some City Slicker that's going
to like take advantage of me and like
start talking about trees in ways that I
don't know or like take advantage of me
and charge me too much yeah so I just
California guys so I put on him over a
barrel I put on a trucker hat because I
had a trucker hat okay and when I put
your accent and I put when I put on it
probably yeah when I put on a trucker
hat
I look like a redneck I mean like I got
this it looks like I have a mullet
but you and you weren't wearing like a
toga I mean most of the time especially
I especially when I'm back in North
Carolina I've got like my you know my
North Face jacket and then it's like a
pair of jeans and like I was wearing
like Duck Boots to be able to walk
around the property so
I put on a hat I look like a local but
you had to think about it
yeah and I guess what I'm saying is if I
was still in North Carolina there would
be enough places that I had to go
regardless of which spiritual path I
took right I still got to show up with
all these people from North Carolina all
the time
and I'm just not like I'm not the guy
that is like
trying to be different right I'm too I'm
I am too interested in being liked to be
too different and I don't like that
about myself I would like to decrease
that but because of that it kind of
keeps me from taking too many risks yeah
to present myself in a way that draws
the wrong kind of attention to me
because if I show up at a place where
it's like hey we're all like guys who
are watching football
my natural tendency is to become a guy
who likes watching football because that
guy's within me I do like watching
football not all the time but I can
become that I'm knowledgeable I can have
conversation nightmare I think I would
be the guy who still watched football
that's totally true if I still live in
North Carolina I would still be watching
sports well I still watch sports here
yeah I and I don't and I am so glad
oh my goodness I'm so there's not
there's no pressure to know about the
sports the reason why I watched the
sports was so that I could be a part of
the conversation yeah so that I wouldn't
be like what you know poor guy he's so
out of touch
right you know out of here there's no
there's no there's no touching there's
no touch football
yeah so I I'm trying to think
I'm trying to think how it manifests
itself beyond the way you dress and the
way you wear I like being different I
like being different I feel like being
in North Carolina I mean especially
the path that we took going from
engineering and then like the campus
Crusade I started to come like in like
I'm the most
like in college like we dress crazy
that's true and it's like
I've gotten back to that you know like
I like being different like expressing
myself and like I feel like I'm getting
back in touch with that fun
high school and college especially
College version of us that was the main
reason for that we got we gave ourselves
permission to be those people because we
were in a band an alternative rock band
and I enjoyed I enjoyed that so much
uh so I feel like I'm
yeah like dressing weird my hair like
this I went to you know I never would go
to a mechanic back home
dressed the way that I went to the
mechanic on uh Friday morning had to get
them to like fix this hole in Lily's
tire and I was teaching her how to do it
I took her with me and like teaching her
how to take a car to a mechanic yeah
and important skill everyone should know
I was like you know we could just we
could plug this ourselves but ain't
nobody got time for that oh I did it and
then that's not what we're talking about
okay good you did it I watched a YouTube
video I don't recommend it I look so
crazy like I did I don't think I could
have brought myself to go to a mechanic
and ask him to do anything you have on a
tank top I had on that that like furry
blue sweater
you saw me right after oh okay yeah yeah
and like the T-shirt it did have a stain
on it and then like what oil stain my
hair and my my weirdo glasses Mission
fuel stain fluid stain so I just feel
like there's no way I'd go to a mechanic
back home dressed like a the weirdo that
I am yeah you'd be taken advantage of
right and it was just like again and
again it's not the type of attention I
want like I'm free to be weird and
nobody bats an eye out here there it's
just like it's you know it's kind of
like that scene where Gandalf is going
through The Hobbit talboton
yeah and everybody's like kind of
sneering at him I feel like
you know and that I don't that'll suck
the pepper out of you man I feel like if
I'd have stayed in North Carolina it was
already sucking the pepper out of me
it's like
that's a that's a huge thing now I will
say
I think Christie's
whenever she she gets in this space
where like she could see herself living
back in North Carolina because to her
interaction with that culture is this
culture out here is much more negative
in terms of like oh and who were you oh
and what do you what are your talents
uh-huh and what do you have to show you
know
are you the you know it's like yeah
that kind of vibe and what can I get
from you what can you give me are you
worth talking to there's like this yeah
and can't go out of your house without
being entirely put together like there's
all these forces out here that will also
they'll they'll they'll wear you down
too in a different way yeah and so
um
because because I like getting attention
and because I am successful let's be
real
I'm you know because I then I'm at home
here you know if it's it's a freedom for
me but it's it it doesn't it doesn't
squish me
and sometimes I totally understand that
people would feel that way being out
here and hate it and then then you look
at how much you're paying for your
mortgage and like I'm paying or your
rent and you're like oh my God why am I
here yeah like we have some neighbors
who just decided to move they would
never move it's like so bummed if it's
not you know if you're not if you're not
making money hand over fist oh God it's
hard to have a family here for sure it's
a tough uh it's a different it's a
different beast and all of that cultural
stuff so it's not all great but it's
like for everybody
um I actually think so uh Jesse loves it
out here doesn't doesn't want to move I
love it out here
don't want to move We're Not Gonna Move
um but I actually think that I could
um so
like I'm not
like I love being out here and being in
the mix and I like being able to
you know I like having so many options
for things to eat and stuff but the
thing is is that
you know the last few times that I've
been to the the triangle I just yeah I
realized that like what is it that I
really enjoy doing
you know okay I like I like having
things at my house out of the way that I
want right yeah and you know I'm pretty
particular about about that like I'm
like you know I'm
I want to be able to get into a sauna
you know what I'm saying I like my
little ice bath that I get in every
morning
you can afford all that stuff so you can
I can do all that in North Carolina no
problem
um I like watching sports I like going
to sporting events I would love to be
able to go to NC State football games
and basketball games I would love to
have season tickets see the Wolfpack
play like I'm still really into it like
I and I can afford like really good
seats I could get close
um I love that I like you know I there's
so many good places to eat now there's
so many of the things that I do
I could still do there yeah
um and also I think that things have
have evolved culturally
in a pretty short period of time
especially if you're in if you're in
Raleigh or in Chapel Hill or Derma
whatever it's just like you know Jesse
and I drove through Carrboro Carrboro
um
and you just get this I was like oh this
is really it's really interesting to be
back here in North Carolina
and have this mix of
like Progressive people but Southern but
Southern tendencies
and those two things definitely exist
together in in droves in many places in
the south
and
I actually think it probably has a lot
to do it's one of those sort of
subconscious reasons why we ended up
getting a place back home was to be able
to stay there a little bit longer you
know yes just to have a place to stay
when we go back and see our families as
our you know parents getting older and
that kind of thing and
um but I think part of it for me was
just recognizing that I you know there's
a lot that I really like about the south
there's a lot that I like about the
triangle
um and now that I've kind of gone out
and done my thing and like a lot of the
things that we do are kind of based on
what we've already done and that we move
into opportunities based on the
opportunities that we've already created
for ourselves that's not ever going away
I'm not saying don't worry I'm not
saying I'm planning on moving I'm just
saying that as I wasn't worried as I
have like a thought exercise
there's not this recoiling in any way
maybe we need to set up a satellite we
can set up a campus mythical campus and
North Carolina and also even what would
happen even when it comes to the uh
the way I present myself yeah okay when
I met the guy with the uh
the tree guy I put a hat on but in a lot
of ways
I just don't think that that's a factor
anymore now that I've lived a life in
which it's not a factor you come out to
a place where it's not a factor it's
like oh I can do
I can look however I want to look I can
talk how I want to talk
I still like I mean the oceans are
better it's nice and hotter the beaches
are better
the beaches are better here in North I'm
talking about North Carolina being
better oh yeah the beaches are better I
like a good Southern
exchange at a gas station
yeah hey where are you where'd you where
are you going to up to whether you get
out you're going to get data directly
kind of a thing
um
yes I I like a I like a good
interaction with the with with some
tilled soil you can get some of that out
here yeah I mean for so for me the
reason that I'm here now
and plan to stay
now first of all Jessie's more committed
to staying than I am
do I mean she just she just loves it and
I love it too but I also
like North Carolina
quite a bit I'm not saying she doesn't
like North Carolina but so yeah I'm much
more but for me I'm just saying that the
main reason I have plans to stay
indefinitely and probably probably die
out here
uh is like you know at an appointed time
well everyone's gonna die at a point in
time but like you know not anytime soon
hopefully
um I'm saying I would I could retire out
here
um it's because it's just where it's
where we've built this thing right and
it's where it's where our team is and
it's where it's where we're operating
right and I don't have any desire to
like try to recreate that in another
place no in the United States no me
neither yeah
well let's shut this down to spend a
good conversation here my recommendation
is the Spotify playlist Tibetan bowls
you know uh see if you can last the five
hours and 21 minutes of listening to
nothing but Tibetan balls do they add
anything besides bowls sometimes there's
a little bit of synth in there you can
do yourself a little meditation
you know focus focus on the moment with
Tibetan bowls
meditative tones for clarity and healing
whatever that means
nobody needs that I just thought it was
cool and if that's not your thing the
new sizza album is uh really growing up
double wreck yeah yeah yeah since I'm
here all right
sending out love no regrets hashtag your
biscuits and of course
join the conversation there and by
calling 188 earpod one
hi my name is James I'm a long time fan
uh I've been in fact I've been watching
since your Caption Fail Videos my very
first video of yours was the Christmas
Caption Fail the most recent episode of
ear biscuits on the chat CPT I found
utterly hilarious uh and it reminded me
of that uh that Caption Fail video
um I just couldn't stop laughing the
whole way through I just wanted to thank
you for bringing back memories the first
time I watched your content
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]